revista de prensa en directo américa de
france 24 me acompaña en el estudio
nuestra periodista rosa pérez más de
eeuu nos vamos a empezar entonces en
medio del análisis internacional que nos
plantea la importancia de ucrania como
gran era europa esto por supuesto en lo
que estaba ocurriendo el día de hoy que
ya zarpó entonces el primer barco
cargado con al menos 26 mil toneladas de
grano ucraniano y todo apunta que puede
ser entonces el maíz que está dentro de
ese barco efectivamente buenos días raúl
y empecemos como bien decía analizando
la importancia agrícola y como
exportadora de alimentos de ucrania como
tal no y es que este país dedica el 71
por ciento de su territorio a la
explotación agrícola y el 14 por ciento
de la población se dedica a la
agricultura y en este mapa con
información de álvaro merino para el
orden mundial como decías vemos en
amarillo los campos dedicados al trigo y
a la cebada y es que ucrania aporta
entre el 9 y el 17 por ciento del
volumen de las exportaciones globales de
este alimento
sin duda en condiciones normales digamos
antes de la guerra por otro lado vemos
en verde los campos de maíz y es que
ucrania porta el 12 por ciento de las
exportaciones mundiales de este grano
también en la naranja el girasol y es
que ucrania es responsable del 46 por
ciento de las exportaciones de girasol
en el mundo no las que se usan para
hacer el aceite de girasol y un 54 por
ciento de las que se usan para hacer
harina de girasol y también antes de la
guerra destacar que el 90 por ciento de
estas exportaciones y de aquí la
importancia de la que es la noticia del
día sin duda esta primera salida de un
barco cargado con gran ucraniano pues el
90 por ciento de estas exportaciones
agrícolas de ucrania se daba por mar
ahora repasemos y vamos a fijarnos rosa
como reseñan los medios internacionales
esta salida del primer barco con granos
desde ucrania que desde que empezó
obviamente la invasión de rusia a este
país exactamente y para y recordar un
poco los datos fundamentales de esta
primera salida recordemos el barco este
él se llama razón y con bandera de
sierra leona que lleva en odessa desde
el 18 de febrero desde antes que
empezara la guerra ya zarpó con 26 mil
toneladas de lo que sería maíz a bordo
en dirección al líbano pero antes va a
pasar por estambul donde mañana va a ser
inspeccionada por este comité conjunto
de las naciones unidas- de turquía de
rusia y de ucrania los que firmaron este
acuerdo que ha permitido finalmente el
desbloqueo de cerca de 20 millones de
toneladas de granos bloqueadas en los
puertos ucranianos del mar negro vienen
dados estos datos empezamos por el 'new
york times' que dice el barco del ratón
y que fue llevó las anclas en el puerto
donde esa fue guiado por un navío del
gobierno a través de un laberinto de
minas que habían sido colocadas por las
fuerzas ucranianas para evitar que moscú
lanzara un ataque por el mar por mar
hacia o de esa y esta salida recordemos
es el primer paso para abordar una de
las consecuencias de mayor alcance de
esta guerra como nos dice new york
times' que es el precio y la
disponibilidad de granos a nivel mundial
pero recuerda este medio estadounidense
que la guerra no es el único factor que
hace que los precios de los granos estén
tan elevados entre otras cosas también
influía el cambio climático porque el
clima cálido y seco reduce el
rendimiento de los campos y es cada vez
más común por otro lado el mont cita a
culé va el ministro exteriores de
ucrania que dice que la reanudación de
la exportación de granos es un alivio
para todo el mundo particularmente para
nuestros amigos de medio oriente y
áfrica el kremlin por su lado también
citado por lemon juzga este avance como
muy positivo pero destacable mont que
mientras se da este desbloqueo continúa
el bombardeo de mykolaiv al yazira
déjame a leer unas líneas a de jong
gendron desde odessa para este medio
dice ha tardado mucho en suceder pero
ahora está surcando las aguas de la
guerra para alimentar el mundo este
barco ha habido obstáculos logísticos
que superar las aguas están minadas y
ahora y ayer escuchamos lo que sonó como
el tercer ataque ruso av desa desde que
se firmó el acuerdo
el barco se fabricó en china en
1996 está lleno de grano nos dicen maíz
y para terminar con este repaso
internacional el south china morning
post' también destaca el alivio para el
mundo pero dicen mientras las
exportaciones el bloqueo de las
exportaciones terminan la guerra
continua como lo abordaba rosa la prensa
rusa y la prensa ucraniana puede ser por
un lado nos hemos fijado en el kiev
independent que básicamente lo destaca
con un pequeño breve no dice el ministro
de infraestructura oleksandr curva tough
anuncio de la salida del barco pero el
kiev post tiene una entrevista con el
mismo ministro de infraestructuras
ucraniano que asegura todas las partes
las partes acordamos que intentaremos
que este acuerdo funcione pero añado que
si vemos riesgo para las tripulaciones
cesaremos el trabajo también agrega que
se está al mismo tiempo trabajando en el
plan b de reforzar los puertos del
danubio y el uso del ferrocarril por
otro lado el kommersant de rusia también
destaca una nota muy informativa
mientras que erc russia today dice se
espera que el buque con destino al
líbano ayude a aliviar el aumento global
de los precios de los alimentos y nos
quedamos en el rate porque detalla la
nueva rutina naval rusa presentado ayer
por el kremlin exactamente en medio de
este foco de atención mediático en el
mar negro rt presenta y desgrana lo que
tenemos que saber de esta nueva doctrina
naval que se presentó coincidiendo con
el día de la marina rusa no dice que
esta nueva doctrina refleja el giro en
el panorama de la geopolítica y la
seguridad global que entre otras cosas
ha desatado esta guerra de ucrania dice
que los intereses nacionales de rusia se
expanden como gran poder naval que rusia
a todos los océanos por otro lado rusia
dice busca promover sus intereses
basándose en principios universalmente
reconocidos del derecho internacional
bien y por otro lado como amenazas
destacadas en esta nueva doctrina la
intención de eeuu de dominar los océanos
del mundo la expansión de la otan hacia
las fronteras rusas y por último destaca
el importante
en el ártico para explotar sus recursos
naturales pero también como el lugar
estratégico militar rosa como siempre
gracias por toda la información mañana
con massa revista de prensa en directo
américa pasamos a saludar a nuestra
primera invitada del día